>> Tucker: IT TOOK A COUPLE
YEARS AND BIG DIP IN
VIEWERSHIP BUT THE NFL HAS
REALIZE THE PUBLIC WAS
TURNED OFF BY THE
CONTROVERSY OVER PLAYERS
KNEELING DURING THE NATIONAL
ANTHEM.
TODAY, ROGER GOODELL WHO
RUNS THE LEAGUE ANNOUNCED
NEW POLICY BANNING PUBLIC
ANTHEM PROTESTS.
THE PLAYERS DON'T WANT TO
STAND, THEY HAVE TO STAY IN
THE LOCKER ROOM OR THEIR
TEAM WILL BE FINED.
ALREADY THE NFL PLAYERS
UNION HAS PROTESTED THE RULE
AND NEW YORK JETS CHAIRMAN
CHRISTOPHER JOHNSON SAYS THE
TEAM WILL SIMPLY PAY THE
FINES IF HIS PLAYERS DECIDE
TO PROTEST.
JASON WHITLOCK IS WITH FOX
SPORTS 1 A FREQUENT GUEST ON
THIS SHOW ANSWERED JOINS US
NOW.
JASON, THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> NO PROBLEM, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: READ THE GOODELL
STATEMENT.
IT READS AS:
ARE THEY GOING TO TAKE
POSITIONS ON GNAT NAFTA OR
TAX POLICY NEXT?
I THOUGHT IT WAS FOOTBALL
LEAGUE, NO?
>> THEY ARE NOT GOING TO, --
LISTEN, I THINK ROGER
GOODELL AND THE NFL ARE
TRYING TO PLEASE EVERYONE.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
>> I'M NOT SURE IF YOU CAN
ACCOMPLISH THAT I THINK SOME
PEOPLE ARE HEARTENED, OKAY,
THE PLAYERS THAT TAKE THE
FIELD WILL BE CALLED UPON TO
STAND AND RESPECT THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM AND THE
FLAG.
BUT I THINK HE HAS OPENED AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
PLAYERS THAT DON'T COME OUT
ON THE FIELD AND THAT WILL
DRIVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
NFL THAT MIGHT BE A BIT
UNCOMFORTABLE AND NOT WHAT
THE LEAGUE WANTS.
I REALLY THINK, TUCKER, THEY
SHOULD HAVE DONE ONE OF TWO
THINGS.
THEYED COULD HAVE SAID TO
THE PLAYERS, LOOK, WE ARE
JUST GOING TO REMOVE THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM FROM YOUR
INVOLVEMENT.
EVERYBODY STAY IN THE LOCKER
ROOM.
WE'LL JUST DO IT WITH OUR
FANS.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN OPTION
ONE.
OPTION TWO, AND IT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN THE ONE I WOULD
HAVE PREFERRED, I WISH HE
WOULD HAVE JUST SAID LOOK,
IF YOU COME OUT AND YOU
DISRESPECT THE NATIONAL
ANTHEM, YOU WON'T PLAY.
YOU WILL STILL GET PAID, BUT
YOU WON'T PLAY.
AND SO, THAT WILL FORCE NFL
OWNERS AND COACHES TO BE A
BIT MORE VIGILANT ABOUT WHO
IS ON THEIR TEAM AND WHETHER
THESE PLAYERS WANT TO HURT
THEIR TEAM BY HONORING THEIR
PROTEST DURING THE GAME
MAKES THEM REAL CONSEQUENCES
FOR THAT PROTEST U AND.
>> Tucker: VERY SMART.
>> THERE SHOULD BE
CONSEQUENCES FOR IT.
>> Tucker: THAT'S A -- KIND
OF A BRILLIANT SOLUTION.
WHY DIDN'T HE DO THAT?
>> I THINK THE GOAL WAS TO
PLEASE EVERYBODY.
PLAYERS, THE LEFT WING MEDIA
THAT HATES FOOTBALL.
AND THEN ALSO TRYING TO
PLEASE THE SPORTS FANS AND
THE ACTUAL CONSUMERS OF
FOOTBALL WHO JUST WANT THE
PLAYERS TO RESPECT THE FLAG,
RESPECT THE ANTHEM AND PUT
ON AN ENTERTAINING GAME.
PEOPLE GO TO SPORTING EVENTS
TO BE DISTRACTED FROM OUR
POLITICS AND DEBATES ABOUT
RACE.
SPORTS AND FOOTBALL STADIUMS
HAVE BEEN WHERE PEOPLE OF
ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT
BACKGROUND, ECONOMICALLY,
RACE, POLITICS, ALL COME
TOGETHER AND ROOT FOR A
COMMON TEAM.
IT HASN'T BEEN A PLACE TO GO
TO DISCUSS SPORTS.
I MEAN, TO DISCUSS POLITICS.
>> Tucker: THAT'S RIGHT.
AND I THINK IT'S GREAT TO
HAVE A RESPITE FROM ALL THIS
INSANITY.
JASON WHITLOCK HOST OF SPEAK